no I wasn't recording this whole time oh
that's so stupid
imagine you're this guy and you've been
putting off writing a thank-you letter
to your grandma she sent you socks or
something for Christmas you even went
and bought the stationery to do it you
have a thank-you letter
nicely wrapped in the what anyway so
basically every time you think about
doing it you start to feel this inner
sense of resistance
it's a resistance you can't seem to
break past so instead of dealing with
that resistance you go and do an
escapist activity like playing Apex
legends so let's continue this roleplay
a little bit you're playing Apex legends
for a couple of hours and things are
going well and then it hits you it's an
inner kind of disgusting guilty feeling
it's as if the anxiety of the thing that
you're avoiding starts to pervade the
activity that you're using to escape the
thing you're avoiding congratulations
in this short little role-playing
totally fictional experiment we just did
you just experienced the two types of
pain the pain of action and the pain of
inaction the pain of action is something
we can all identify with
it's that discomfort we feel before we
do anything constructive any time you
think about doing something that's
constructive and a little bit difficult
there's that inner sense of resistance
that seems to stop you from doing it and
in order to actually accomplish that
thing you have to break through that
resistance and then you get it done that
inner sense of resistance is like it's a
paralyzing feeling breaking through this
resistance usually takes some good old
white-knuckle willpower so while it's
painful and uncomfortable up front if
you just take it on the chin and deal
with it you start to become stronger and
more able to deal with it in the future
you start to become somebody who is okay
with discomfort your confidence your
self-efficacy and basically your whole
life improves because not only do you
feel better about yourself usually doing
something constructive makes your life
situation better anyways it's kind of
like a lose win the lose is eating the
pain and that win is the redemption that
comes from that pain so that's the pain
of action the pain of inaction is far
more subtle and it's a lot more sinister
to and that's because it doesn't usually
feel like pain at
all when you choose to play apex instead
of filing your taxes it may actually
feel good for a while and you know it's
a lot more fun to play apex than it is
to file your taxes but kind of like
binge drinking on a Friday night you're
just stealing the happiness from
Saturday morning and the debt you'll
have to repay afterwards is far more
painful than just taking the initial
pain on the chin to begin with the pain
of inaction is a slow-burning
degenerative pain that ruins every
aspect of your life by choosing the
inaction route you become a softer
person somebody who flinches at the
sight of discomfort somebody who can't
get stuff done and the consequence of
that on a long enough timeline is you
start to dislike yourself you start to
not believe in your ability to get
things done and your life situation
starts to fall apart around you you'll
eventually dig yourself into a hole so
deep that it seems impossible to get out
of until you're pained by the misery of
your own existence obviously this is
really morbid but it's nonetheless true
nobody can avoid pain in day to day life
pain is just something that we all have
to deal with but thankfully we can
choose which pain we deal with if you
choose not to fool yourself and take the
pain right upfront battle through the
discomfort of taking constructive action
then you won't have this massive pain
debt to pay and the pain debt is the
pain of inaction which is a lot more
crappy in general so yeah that's all
that's all I got to say is choose wisely
I think that's pretty much all I'm gonna
say it's good to be back I just wanted
to throw I actually put a lot of thought
into this video as short as it is I've
been thinking about pain in general and
like how sometimes life sucks but
there's a lot of redemption to be found
in this pain as long as you're aware of
it and make the right decisions anyways
not to get too preachy or anything so
I'm gonna do a giveaway I've just
decided this now so the folks over at
habit nest they send me the nutrition
sidekick journal I don't even know if
this is good or not I'm just gonna be
straight up with you I haven't opened it
yet it's brand new in its packaging and
you could be the first to tell me how it
is click the link in the description
there's just it's like super easy to
sign up for this giveaway it's just a
gleam dot IO
and you have a really good chance of
winning this in general because we don't
have a giant subscriber base of millions
of subscribers so your chances are
pretty good thank you for watching I
hope you liked this video as per usual
if you like this video hit that like
button if you like videos like these in
general hit that subscribe button join
our Facebook page it is actually one of
the coolest parts about this channel we
have over 1200 members on our Facebook
page just sharing their advice tips and
tricks as to how to improve how to be
better in social situations how to
improve their diet all these things and
we're going to open a discord very soon
where you can actually talk you can
actually hear people's voices which is
exciting who doesn't like to hear
people's voices anyway that's all for
today thank you for watching and we'll
catch you in the next video
[Music]